il devait être avec nous la semaine
dernière il est rétabli cette semaine
voici andré glucksmann
bonsoir rochât vous venez c'est tout le
monde bien ça alors vous avez vu
l'affrontement nab beigbeder la semaine
dernière la télévision et non j'ai rien
vu vous étiez là oui c'était à ce point
là donc oui d'accord alors beigbeder on
a découvert dans cette émission rejoint
l'opposition briguent luxe man celle de
seul de pascal bruckner de goupil et
même un petit peu de kouchner en
devenant un inconditionnel
des américains voilà alors on va en
parler tout au long de votre interview
puisque vous publié chez plon un bouquin
qui s'appelle ou est contre ouest voilà
le pitch un très simplement c'est un
plaidoyer pour la guerre la guerre en
irak que vous que vous soutenez que que
vous justifier et puis deuxièmement la
guerre contre le nid vise mais pour la
civilisation on peut dire que pour vous
lira que c'est une guerre humanitaire à
aider les irakiens à se débarrasser de
saddam hussein au nom du devoir
d'ingérence c'est une bonne chose
écoutez d'abord je ne suis pas un
inconditionnel des américains ouais je
suis un inconditionnel de la chute de
saddam hussein alors l'avenir de l'irak
vous voyez comment parce qu'il ya deux
solutions comme ça qui à l'horizon il ya
soit une libanisation de l'irak soit ira
nisation d'irak alors soit c'est lié
liban c'est à dire le chaos
multiconfessionnelle avec les gi's dans
le bourbier ça c'est le liban soit on
fait des élections au suffrage universel
vous savez bien ça devient une
république islamique un peu comme en
iran c'est ce que j'appelle les
organisations alors entre les deux
solutions laquelle vous préférez un
troisième à section à cette troisième
solution là c'est un minimum de
démocratie un minimum d'état de droit
seule une paix qui règne quand même dans
les 2/3 de l'irak parce que là où il ya
du terrorisme c'est le triangle sunnite
1 c'est pas c'est pas l'ensemble de
guéret ni chez les kurdes n'y croyez que
l'irak va échapper au destin du liban
destin de l'iran il va aller vers un
destin je dirais démocratique et
pacifique mais ce que je voudrais c'est
que ni souhaité j'en doute pas mais le
elle destin du liban d'avant un mois je
ne suis pas raciste 1 je ne pense pas
que les arabes par définition n'aime pas
la liberté
je ne pense pas que aujourd'hui les
maires irakienne qui voit les gens du
bath où les gens de ben laden ou les
deux détruire les conduites d'eau
détruire les conduites d'électricité
considère que ce terrorisme lassé de la
résistance que c'est bien et que ça
représente le peuple parce qu'il est je
voulais dire andré c'est que vous pensez
qu'il va y avoir un sursaut démocratique
irakien et que l'irak finalement cette
formidable ça va être une vraie
démocratie et que les américains vont
partir là là là vous me rendez vous il
dit que ces hommes disent que c'est la
troisième chute ça va être formidable
pour la bosnie 1 ça a pris sept ans le
kosovo ça dure déjà depuis quelques
années c'est quand même mieux le travail
qu'a fait kouchner n'a alors qu'en
kouchner dit qu' il faut aider les
américains les critiques et en les
aidant qu'il faut soutenir les efforts
de son ami qui est mort maintenant
sérgio moi je pense qu'il a raison il ya
l'expérience du kosovo qui parle il ya
l'expérience du timor qui parle les gens
ne sont pas condamnés quand ils ne sont
pas européens à la servitude à l'
esclavage et à la terre d'accord alors
dans votre bouquin vous critiquez
beaucoup l'onu 1 vous lui reprocher
d'avoir laissé massacrer des millions de
victimes depuis
1945 ou dit le conseil de ce qui a été
je suis prêt si il ya quand même le
génocide du cambodge n'ont rien fait sur
le site du rwanda où l'onu s'est tiré
parce qu'elle était sur place mais vous
avez raison bien sûr c'est vrai que le
conseil de sécurité étant toujours
divisé le nul ne peut pas agir par
définition mais alors depuis que vous
avez écrit ce bouquin le président bush
a fait appel à l'onu donc cette nuque
est incapable et dont il ne voulait pas
il ya six mois aujourd'hui finalement il
devient la solution de tous les
problèmes tournée c'est pas depuis que
j'ai écrit des bouquins parce qu'à vrai
dire le président bush a fait appel à
l'onu avant même de faire la guerre
ouais hein c'est la france qu à me lever
tôt 1 c'est pas de ces pas les
américains qui ont abandonné le hainaut
est alors depuis que j'ai écrit deux
bouquins il ya quand même un exemple qui
dit tout à fait ce que je pense
et que ce que je pense c'est possible
c'est l'exemple du liberia 1 le
dictateur qui est un affreux dictateur
aussi qu'est l'or dont le charme sénat
il est finalement parti sans guerre mais
avec des pressions militaires
extrêmement forte il y avait les bateaux
achetés pour l'irak ça voilà ben voilà
c'est ce que cette tenue qui a été
tellement méprisé par boucher essai néo
conservateurs pensais qu'aujourd'hui ça
devient la solution nous c'est pas la
solution la solution vrai hein c'est
l'union des démocraties donc là on vient
de voir l'irak avant de passer et ça
c'est la première guerre c'est la guerre
contre saddam hussein après on va passer
à la guerre contre le contre le
nihilisme et pour la civilisation est ce
que c'est des questions à poser à andré
glucksmann qui est là
simpliste du monde et moi je crois qu'on
va aller vers une
dérive à la congo en irak avec une
exploitation des richesses du pays par
des grosses sociétés des grosses
sociétés pétrolières et et des
gouvernements qui vont qui viennent je
pense pas qu'un concept de démocratie à
l'européenne fonctionne dans les pays
latins andré va vous dire que si vous
pensez si vous pensez que les
informations coeur d'un scénario
classique c'est une forme de racisme
d'escudé telle qu on la pense nous que
j'ai du mal avec le rapport anti
américain pro américain et pro guerre
anti guerre il ya juste un vrai problème
aujourd'hui c'est la crédibilité du
gouvernement américain en tant que tel
parce qu'ils sont allés face à l'ô nu en
train de dire et ça ça c'est des armes
chimiques qu'il faut aller au combat
c'était un peu ridicule il y avait
peut-être d'autres manières de
convaincre l'onu moi je suis plutôt en
accord avec vous sur ce terrain là moi
j'ai du mal à croire le gouvernement le
gouvernement bush et l'administration
bush aujourd'hui continue à mentir et
continue à mentir de tout de toutes les
façons et c'est un petit peu difficile
de parfois de les soutenir voilà et
quand il parle de bioterrorisme il
ferait mieux de ratifier les accords de
kyoto qui vont engendrer des grandes
catastrophes dans les 50 ans à venir
notamment
multiplication de certains cancers
disparition de pays comme le bangladesh
est là ce monsieur là est en train de
faire en bien pire que le le père noël
noir ben laden qu'on nous ressort le 11
septembre pour faire peur aux serial des
vidéos
que bush soient critiquables qui bien
sûr bien sûr qu'il que les américains
ont eu tort de soutenir l'arabie
saoudite depuis 1945 qui est un régime
esclavagiste
intégristes et où absolument vrai sauf
que quand il rectifie quand tout à coup
il s'aperçoit que les twin towers elles
sont tombés parce qu'il y avait quinze
pilotes saoudien que ben laden ait
saoudien que le pognon venait d'arabie
saoudite que l'idéologie vient de
l'arabie saoudite et que finalement ils
se rendent compte que la liberté des
saoudiens ou des afghans
dont il se fichait totalement
tout à coup ça intervient sur les tours
de new york alors je dis pas plus ils
sont des grand grand grand idéaliste
mais ils ont le souci eux de leur
sécurité et se sont aperçus que leur
alliance avec arabie saoudite après une
catastrophe à nu
nicolas est là on se dit d'accord avec
la pollution de huit semaines non je
suis pas d'accord dans la caricature de
la position de la france qu'est ce que
demandaient les chirac sait que
simplement on fasse pression pour faire
partir saddam hussein n'est pas avec une
attaque préméditée et des mensonges
alors quand le président a un public a
dit que c'était des mensonges tout le
monde a ri au nez en disant qu'on
voulait défendre saddam hussein c'était
une caricature par les américains de la
position française est l'exemple du
liberia tout à fait parlants on aurait
pu attendre un peu et justement faire
partir saddam hussein sans rentrer dans
cette guerre comme rentrer dans cette
guerre qui a des conséquences
collatérales considérable je souhaite
que ça finisse comme le dit andré
glucksmann mais je le crains parce que
les chiffres vont vouloir mettre en
place une autre dictature une dictature
islamique et aux soins très dangereuse
gerra
quand colombien a demandé d'enregistrer
cet album je me suis dit bon qu'est-ce
que je vais véhicules et
je vais chanter l'amour est
bon voilà ça c'est fait c'est un peu
magique c'est pas mal oui donc ça donc
s'appelle au milieu de la nuit
alors on continue et on termine donc
avec l'autre guerre parce que les la
guerre contre saddam hussein et votre
bouquin comme j'étais un vrai plaidoyer
pour ça et puis à la guerre beaucoup
plus grave parce que ça débouche sur une
guerre mondiale pratiquement c'est ce
que vous appelez la guerre contre le
nihilisme et pour la civilisation c'est
le titre de votre bouquin d'ailleurs
tout dépend en dites-vous de l'analyse
qu'on fait du 11 septembre pour certains
pour nabeul par exemple on cette forme
c'est pas un crime c'est un châtiment on
sent lui laisse la responsabilité de ses
propos ensuite il ya ceux qui
considèrent ce un accident fait un truc
s'est passé comme ça sans voilà c'est
ensuite il ya ceux comme nous considère
que c'est un tournant pour vous c'est un
tournant historique
et vous appelez les attardés du 10
septembre hier ce sont pas compris
c'était un tournant dans l'histoire du
monde est ce que j'ai fait les réveiller
du 11 septembre c'est à dire dont on
vous dit de faire partie car pour vous
finalement son septembre c'est pas juste
un accident de l'histoire c'est un
tournant historique
d'ailleurs ça l'a été pour tout le monde
et puis après on s'est mis à refouler
par ses propos inquiétants quand on dit
ground zero pour désigner manhattan ont
fait allusion à quoi et personne ne
s'est posé la question personne n'a
protesté c'est ça coulait de source
quatre heures après la la taxe est une
agence qui a parlé de grands héros pour
désigner les ruines de manhattan mais
grande 0 c'est quoi c'est le terrain
expérimental au nouveau mexique où a été
lancé la dernière bombe avant hiroshima
la bombe atteint donc les gens ont
l'impression qu'il y avait là un pouvoir
dévastateur qui changeait tout - parce
que jusqu'à jusqu'à maintenant jusqu'au
10 septembre
le pouvoir de dévaster le monde de
mettre fin à l' aventure humaine c'était
cette puissance nucléaire bon on leur
délégué cette responsabilité une
question simple est ce que pour vous le
11 septembre c'est le début de la
troisième guerre mondiale mais non c'est
pas une guerre mondiale comme ça la
guerre mondiale elle est menée par ceux
qui assassinent les populations civiles
dans les pays musulmans en afrique en
tchétchénie en chine
voyez le tibet savez très bien quand
même que la france est unis par faction
interposés depuis depuis 15 ans se
livrent une guerre en a sur tout le
continent africain qui m'allume
france etats unis en afrique terry la
france a soutenu le roi les hutus du
rwanda sur le thème fachoda c'est pour
faire échec aux anglo saxons est ce que
l'on pensait est-ce que vous pensez que
le 21e siècle pourrait voir la
disparition de l'occident absolument
mais aussi la disparition de l'humanité
par tranches un
procédé de claire c'est que l'europe
aujourd'hui enfin nous ne suit pas
l'europe en tant que tel mais nous
européens on doit choisir notre camp
c'est ce que vous dites mais on doit
choisir notre camp mais ça veut pas dire
choisir le camp des américains les
américains avant le 11-septembre se
fichait de ce qui se passait en
afghanistan et ça leur a coûté cher
s'entendait avec les intégristes et ça
leur a coûté cher je dis pas du tout
qu'il faille se mettre derrière les
américains je dis qu'il faut lutter
contre ce nihilisme qui fait que au nom
avec une kalachnikov on terrorise les
gens qui n'en n'ont pas la lutte contre
les nice c'est à dire ceux qui se
croient tout permis avec une claque
kalachnikov contre les populations
civiles il faut absolument lutter contre
eux la plupart du temps lutte avec des
idées avec la propagande avec tout ce
qu'on veut quelquefois il faut lutter
avec des armes moi je suis né en europe
occupée ma famille était résistante à
trois ans j'avais pas mon nom je
m'appelle joseph rivière ac 5 ans
j'avais les clés d'une planque où il y
avait des armes puis évidemment j'étais
pas très sérieux un bon mais j'ai appris
qu'il fallait résister et j'ai appris
aussi que quand on la résistance n'était
pas assez forte et qu'il y avait une
armée qui débarquait qu'elle était
composée d'américains tonglet de
canadiens et ben moi j'étais bien
content c'est une armée qui a n'ont pas
conquis le continent mais libéré le
continent et qui a apporté la liberté
aux européens j'espère que c'est comme
ça que ça se passera merci d'avoir la
légion
voilà online luxe man ouest en reste aux
émissions tour mesdames messieurs